in 2016 this was a very confusing place
to be designing streets is a little bit
like being a detective if you look hard
enough you can see the traces of all the
decisions people made before claire is
the principal in charge of wxy an
architecture firm with a focus on urban
design planning and community-based
architecture i'm going to walk you
through three street redesigns that wxy
has done in new york city
sometimes you hear the term bad street
there's no vegetation there's nothing to
look at there's nothing to visit
generally people will go oh my god
that's not a street i want to walk down
and therefore it's not a great street
and the opportunity as an architect or
landscape architect or urban designer is
to kind of see what's happening really
listen and
observe because there needs to be design
solutions to the problems that people
are experiencing on their streets let's
talk about cooper union cooper union is
an intersection in new york where bowery
splits off into cooper square the
original street only
did this
the bowery was widened and there were
too many lanes for cars and not enough
crosswalks for pedestrians what's really
interesting is that departments of
transportation were actually departments
of cars for a long time and mostly they
would describe streets by the number of
lanes the street ultimately expanded to
four lanes of traffic which resulted in
a very confusing intersection we're
seeing everything being two ways two
moving lanes in every direction but
confusion in the middle and here's our
sidewalk that is a lot of road bed
because if i was looking at just dotting
in you know what a street would be right
i'm left with a kind of no-man zone here
for pedestrians there's no clear way to
cross the intersection so the way people
have tried to deal with it is where you
see all sorts of painted medians all
over the place to try and kind of tell
people what they should be doing and it
was completely car focused which didn't
add much to the character of the street
the bigger you make roads the more it
attracts traffic but it doesn't really
attract things like business more
cyclists more walking in a lot of ways
it's a kind of a human behavior issue
the solution reduce the number of lanes
add pedestrian crosswalks and limit the
direction of traffic instead of a bunch
of streets
you have a very straightforward way for
cars even which they could not do before
to drive up the street which is now one
way
and what that's done is it's made more
sidewalks and that's really
fundamentally what you're seeing with
street design is a way to make streets
still serve cars efficiently but also
make it easier for people on buses
people biking all of these
kinds of lanes can kind of shift
priorities and give new spaces now let's
head to brooklyn to take a look at alby
square albe square is an intersection in
downtown brooklyn where fleet fulton
street alby square west and bond street
all meet up but many of the subways are
sort of off to the corner on very narrow
sidewalks this area has a lot of
pedestrian traffic but not a lot of
space to maneuver especially since these
are small historical streets when you
have historic streets they're not always
as wide as connector streets that got
cleared out because people wanted more
lanes so a lot of the planning that's
happening around albe square in these
remnants of different grids that make up
downtown brooklyn and all the new
buildings is to create more room
what do we see on the right hand side
well all of a sudden this street right
here isn't there anymore but now this
street
meets
we have a much larger public space
instead of an island surrounded by
streets we have an island that's now
attached to
the sidewalk for
a beautiful bank building
and a new mall called alby square mall
that's full of activity next up is astor
place we're at pretty well well-known
destination in new york called astor
place esther place is an intersection
where lafayette 8th street 4th avenue
and cooper square all converge these are
streets that are doing a lot of work in
2016 this was a very confusing place to
be wide streets narrow streets
there's a lot of buses hanging out
waiting so people just walked in the
street that's the subway and there's
a number of kind of geometries of
streets
all cutting through it that is called
the almo the people have nicknamed the
cube you see people hang out underneath
it the cube is kind of sitting on also
kind of a floating concrete median and
then we have a street
here
known as lafayette street that is going
uptown in addition to these main streets
astor place has a number of historical
streets all feeding into the traffic
flow this where i'm drawing this dotted
line is one of the oldest streets in new
york and it got renamed stuyvesant
street this street must have started as
a dirt path and in fact a lot of streets
in new york center street lafayette
broadway were actually just trails and
then they got widened they got paved
these multifunctional streets home to
art installation subway stops and
historical remnants of old new york are
prone to the wear and tear of high
traffic areas this is not a low space
but there's a lot of flooding that
happens if rain comes really really
quickly
what you see now today not only is there
more trees but there's actually bio
swales and green infrastructure there's
more bike racks there's bigger sidewalks
you have a huge number of additional
green
spaces and trees there's something
called the curb line and the art i think
of street making is figuring out where
the curb goes so that all the buildings
look and feel even better if you put the
curb too close to a building or in the
wrong alignment the whole street feels
off so it's sort of like a great room or
how clothes fit
where the curb is is kind of like the
tailoring of streets
we can start
thinking about streets kind of like air
and water as the
thing that we share there are private
streets but in general successful
important streets are shared by just a
multiplicity of players right and even
by walking so streets in a sense are the
design problem of today to accommodate
getting more out of them and making them
attractive to people but they're also
the design problem of the near future
[Music]